[موسيقى]
مساء الخير جنسب الى وينستن تشيرش للزعيم
البريطاني الشهير انه قال مره ان
الامريكان لا يتخذون القرار السليم الا
بعد ان يستنفذ كل الخيارات
الخاطئه اذا اردت برهانا على هذه المقوله
فما عليكم الا ان تتامل قرار اداره بايدن
بضرب جماعه الحوثي في اليمن بدايه من 12
يناير
2024 بشكل
متكرر الضربات الامريكيه جاءت ردا على
هجمات الحوثيين على سفن ذاهبه او قادمه من
اسرائيل القرار الامريكي هو في تقديري
الاسوا بين كل الخيارات المطروحه وقد يؤدي
لتداعيات خطيره ليس فقط لدول المنطقه ولا
دول العالم بل للولايات المتحده نفسها كيف
ولماذا هذا يتطلب ان نفهم ما يجري في
البحر الاحمر والمياه المؤديه اليه بحر
العرب وخليج عدن وصولا الى قناه السويس
عبر باب المندب مع اندلاع الحرب في غزه
قرر الحوثيون الذين يسيطرون على معظم شمال
اليمن التضامن مع الفلسطينيين
بطريقتين الاولى محاوله ضرب اسرائيل
بصواريخ
ودرون والثانيه منع اي سفن تخرج من
اسرائيل او تتجه اليها من الابحار في
سواحل اليمن واليمن طبعا بيتحكم في مضيق
باب المندب وبالتالي يتحكم في كل السفن
المتجهه لخليج العقبه حيث الاردن واسرائيل
وخليج السويس حيث قناه السويس المصريه
والمعبر الدول بالغ
الاهميه الحوثيين اكدوا في بياناتهم انهم
سوف يوقفون الهجمات على السفن المتجهه
لاسرائيل اذا بدات اسرائيل بالسماح بدخول
المساعدات لغزه وهيو قفوا كل الهجمات على
اسرائيل نفسها بمجرد ان توقف الهجوم على
الفلسطينيين او العدوان على
الفلسطينيين يقينا تمكن الحوثيون من الحاق
الضرر
بالاسرائيليين حتى وان كان حجم هذا الضرر
محل خلاف لكن اسرائيل لم تكن المتضرر
الوحيد من الموقف الحوثي فقد ادت هجماتهم
في المياه الدوليه لاضطرابات خطيره في
البحر الاحمر وهو ثاني اهم ممر ملاحي في
العالم بعد مضيق ملقى ومنه يمر نحو
12% من تجاره العالم قرر عدد كبير من
شركات الملاحه تجنب العبور في ا باب
المندب وقناه السويس ولجوا الى الطريق
البديل الاقدم والاطول وهو راس الرجاء
الصالح ما ادى بطبيعه الحال لارتفاع كبير
في تكاليف الشحن البحري بشكل قد يهدد
الاقتصاد العالمي ان طال امد الازمه كان
امام الامريكان خيارين رئيسيين لايقاف
هجمات الحوثي الاول عسكري وهو ضرب
الحوثيين بهدف اضعاف قدراتهم على تهديد
الملاحه والثاني سياسي وفحواه الاستجابه
لمطلبهم والسعي لانهاء الحرب في غزه
الخيار الاول فاشل بامتياز والقرار الثاني
صائب بامتياز حتى بالمعايير الامريكيه
لماذا لان هجمات الحوثيين وان اربكت
الملاحه الدوليه هي محدده الهدف وهو وقف
الحرب في غزه ووقف الحرب يكاد يكون محل
اجماع معظم دول العالم يعني الجمعيه
العامه صوتت في 12 ديسمب سمبر الماضي
باغلبيه ساحقه لصالح قرار يطالب بوقف فوري
لاطلاق النار في غزه لاسباب
انسانيه الموافقه تمت باغلبيه 153 دوله
وكانت الولايات المتحده واسرائيل من بين
10 دول فقط رفضوا او يعني عارضوا القرار
فيما امتنع 23 دوله عن التصويت وفي كل
الاحوال بعد اكثر من 180 108 يوم من بدء
الحرب انا بسجل الحلقه دي يوم الاثنين
22 يناير 24 لابد من وقف حرب غزه الحرب لن
تستمر الى
الابد ولابد من وقفها ليس فقط لاسباب
انسانيه ولكن لعدم جدواها بعد ان اتضح
للجميع عجز اسرائيل عن تحقيق ا من اهدافها
المعلنه بالقوه العسكريه لم ينجحوا في
استعاده اسراهم لم يقضوا على حماس لم
يحققوا الامن لاسرائيل ولن يحققوه ووقف
الحرب مطلب من قوى مقدره داخل اسرائيل
والولايات
المتحده نفسها
يعني لكن بايدن غير راغب وغير قادر على
الضغط على نتنياهو لفعل ذلك وبدلا من وقف
الحرب قرر ضرب الحوثيين هذا القرار سيؤدي
على الارجح لثلاثه نتائج سيئه مره ثانيه
ليس للعالم ولكن للولايات المتحده نفسها
النتيجه الاول الاولى السيئه اتساع نطاق
الحرب وهذا ما لا تريده الولايات المتحده
برده مش انا اللي بقول كده عدد كبير جدا
من المسؤولين الامريكان بيؤكد منذ 7
اكتوبر والى الان حرص الولايات المتحده
الا يتسع نطاق الحرب ولذلك مثلا عارضت
وضغطت على اسرائيل ال تشن هجوما على حزب
الله خمس مسؤولين في اداره بايدن تحدثوا
الى الى موقع بوليتيكو الامريكي المعروف
قبيل زياره بيدن لاسرائيل في منتصف اكتوبر
الماضي بعد هجوم 7 اكتوبر وقالوا ان زياره
بايدن لاسرائيل لها هدفان الاول معلن وهو
اظهار الدعم لاسرائيل والثاني غير معلن
وهو التاكد من عدم جر اسرائيل للولايات
المتحده الى حرب في الشرق الاوسط لان هذا
قد يحرفها عن اولوياتها الاخرى دي اول
نتيجه سيئه النتيجه الثانيه انه الهجمات
على الحوثيين قد تؤدي الى نسف تفاهمات
التهدئه بين السعوديه والحوثيين والتي
حققت نجاحا نسبيا وبالتالي تهدد استقرار
دول الخليج وهو ما لا تريده ايضا الولايات
المتحده دول الخليج كلها الول حليفه
لامريكا ثلاثه مفاقمه ازمه الاقتصاد
العالمي بمزيد من التوتر في البحر الاحمر
وخليج عدن ليه يتفاقم الازمه ببساطه لان
الحوثي لن يفعل ما فعله امبراطور اليابان
ويظهر ليعلن استسلامه للامريكان وسوف يرد
الضربات الامريكيه بضربات اخرى والمساله
سوف تطول وهو قطعا ما لا تريده امريكا
ولذلك غالبيه دول العالم لم تشارك ولم
تبارك القرار الامريكي المتهور بضرب
الحوثيين بشكل متكرر بدايه من 12 يناير
الجاري الدليل على كده ايه ان امريكا سعت
لما بدات هجمات الحوثيين اظن بدايه من 19
نوفمبر الماضي سعت لتكوين حشد دولي
لمواجهه
الحوثي واعلنت في 19 ديسمبر الماضي عن
تكتل اطلقت عليه عمليه حارس الرخاء في
البحر الاحمر وخليج عدن لكن هذا التكتل
فشل فشلا ذريعا لان معظم دول العالم اما
امتنعت عن المشاركه او شاركت بشكل رمزي
جدا او شاركت في الخفاء والمشاركه في
الخفاء تعني بالضروره دورا محدودا ما هو
ما فيش دوله تقدر تتكتم على ارسال عدد
كبير جدا من قطعها البحريه لكن تقدر تتكتم
على مشاركه عدد محدود جدا من جنودها فرنسا
مثلا قالت ان لها قطع بحريه في المنطقه
لكن هذه القطعه البحريه سوف تظل تحت
القياده الفرنسيه ولن تنضم للحمله
الامريكيه ايطاليا واسبانيا ودول بلدين
اعلنت امريكا في البدايه انهما سيشاركان
في عمليه حارس الازدهار اللي هدفها احتواء
الحوثي في منطقه البحر
الاحمر اصدر بيانات فحواها الناي بانفسهن
عن
الامريكان وزاره الدفاع الايطاليه قالت
انها سوف ترسل الى البحر الاحمر سفنا او
سفينه بناء على طلب من اصحاب السفن
التجاريه الايطاليه وليست كجزء من العمليه
الامريكيه اسبانيا قالت انها لن تنضم الى
حارس الرخاء النتيجه ان امريكا حين قررت
الهجوم العسكري على الحوث في 12 يناير
الماضي لم تجد الا حليفتها الدائمه
بريطانيا واضطرت ل اعلان عن ان هذه
الهجمات هي ضربات ثنائيه بعيدا عن حارس
الازدهار اي انها شنتها مع بريطانيا فقط
وبدعم محدود ورمزي من استراليا نيوزيلندا
كندا بالاضافه طبعا الى البحرين ليس صعبا
ان نفهم سبب احجام كثير من دول العالم على
دعم الضربات الامريكيه على الحوثي رغم ان
الهجمات الحوثيه والانشطه الحوثيه في
البحر الاحمر وخليج عدن بتضر كل هذه
الدول المساله ببساطه ان كثير من دول
العالم باتت تعتقد ان ما يجري في غزه
جريمه يجب على الاقل ان لم يتمكنوا من
وقفها ان ينقوا بانفسهم عنها ويخشون طبعا
ان انضموا لضرب الحوثيين الداعمين لغزه ان
يفسر ذلك على الاقل داخل شوارعهم الغاضبه
مما يجري في غزه ان يفسر على انه دعم
للعدوان
اسرائيلي ده سبب والسبب الاخر هو الخوف من
تعريض انفسهم لانتقام الحوثيين ومفاقمة
ذلك او من ان يجعل ذلك السفن الهنديه
هدفا لهجمات الحوثيين او
لضربات وهذا ياخذنا بقى الى موقف الدول
العربيه مما يجري في البحر الاحمر او
تحديدا الهجمات الامريكيه على الحوثي حتى
تاريخ تسجيل هذه الحلقه اللي هو 22
يناير تجنبت كل الدول العربيه باستثناء
البحرين الانضمام على الاقل علنا الى
عمليه حارس الازدهار او الهجوم الامريكي
البريطاني المباشر على
الحوثيين كل الدول حتى الدول الاكثر تضررا
من النشاط الحوثي مصر الاردن السعوديه
ولذلك يعني لهذا الموقف العربي في تقديري
اربعه اسباب رئيسيه السبب الاولاني طبعا
هو حاله الغضب في الشارع في كل هذه الدول
من العدوان الاسرائيلي المدعوم امريكيا
على غزه ومحاوله تهجير
اهلها صواريخ الحوثي هي تضامن مع الضحيه
ضد اسرائيل وداعمه الاكبر امريكا بديهي ان
حكومات دول المنطقه تخشى ان انضمت الى
التحالف الذي تقوده امريكا ضد الحوثييين
ان تستفز شعوبها التي سوف ترى في هذه
الخطوه تضمنا ودعما لاسرائيل واسكات لواحد
من الاطراف القليله التي انبرت لدعم
الفلسطينيين بالوسائل
العسكريه وبعض هذه الدول يرى ان هجمات
الحوثي وان اضرت بمصالحهم لكن هي في حقيقه
الامر مجرد احد تداعيات ازمه العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه وفروا كل هذا الجهد
الجهد اللي هو متمثل في العدوان على
الحوثي
و اضغطوا على اسرائيل لوقف الحرب وسوف
تتوقف هجمات الحوثيين تلقائيا ده السبب
الاولاني السبب الثاني ان دول الخليج
وخاصه السعوديه والامارات لا ترغب في
استفزاز الحوثيين بشكل ينسف جهود التهدئه
معهم لان هذا يعني استئناف هجمات الحوثيين
على هذه
الدول وطبعا السبب الثالث ان انضمام هذه
الدول للتحالف الامريكي ضد الحوثيين قد
ينسف ليس فقط جهود التهدئه مع الحوثي ولكن
الانفراج الاخيره التي تحققت بينه وبين
تهران اللي هي الداعم الرئيسي للحوثيين
علشان نفهم السبب الثاني والسبب الثالث
بشكل اوضح لابد من خلفيه سريعه اذكركم ان
الحوثيين استولوا على صنعاء العاصمه يعني
العاصمه اليمنيه وجزء كبير من غرب اليمن
بدايه من
2014 السعوديه قادت التحالف هدفه الاطاحه
السريعه بالحوثيين واعاده الحكومه الشرعيه
التي كانت وقتها برئاسه الجنرال عبد ربو
منصور
هادي المهمه التي توقع السعوديون وحلفائهم
انجازها في عده اسابيع لم تنتهي حتى الان
واسوا من ذلك ان الحوثيين تمكنوا بدعم من
ايران من ضرب العمق السعودي
والاماراتي مرات عديده استقرت الاوضاع بعد
نحو تسع سنوات من الحرب على يمن مقسم بين
شمال يسيطر على الحوثيون وجنوب تسيطر عليه
الحكومه الشرعيه المدعومه من السعوديه
والامارات ادركت الامارات والسعوديه عدم
جدوى الخيار العسكري انسحبت الامارات من
اليمن في 2019 وان ظلت تتمتع بحضور كبير
من خلال حلفائها في الجنوب فقط وبدا
السعوديون في التفاوض مع سلطه الامر
الواقع وهم الحوثيون بدايه من 2021
هدف التفاوض ببساطه الخروج من هذا
المستنقع والتفرغ لتحقيق اهم اهدافها وهي
نهده اقتصاديه كبيره بعيدا عن النفط لكن
طبعا لا يمكن تحقيق هذه الطموحات
الاقتصاديه الكبيره تحت تهديد صواريخ
الحوثي لموانئ ومنشات هذ الحيويه بدون
استقرار لن تتمكن السعوديه من مواصله
انتاج وتصدير النفط الذي سوف تمول عوائده
هذه النهضه ولن تتمكن السعود من ان تكون
مركزا للسياحه والطيران الى اسفرت
المفاوضات التي رعتها سلطنه عمان بشكل
رئيسي واطراف اخرى عن هدنه لمده شهرين
بدايه من ابريل
2022 ثم قاموا بتمديدها مرتين وعلى الرغم
من انتهاء الهدنه رسميا في اكتوبر
22 الا انها لا تزالوا ساريه عمليا الى حد
كبير والعنف في اليمن اقل بكثير ثير من
مستوياته ما قبل الهدنه وتوقف الحوثيون عن
مهاجمه السعوديه والامارات في 2023 تطورت
هذه المفاوضات اكثر بزياره لوفد سعودي
لصنعاء في ابريل 23 ثم زياره لوفد حوثي
للرياض في سبتمبر من نفس العام وكانت
المفاوضات تتطور الى ما يمكن ان يكون وقفا
دائما للحرب ثم جاءت حرب غزه في 7 اكتوبر
ودخل الحوث على الخط بدايه من منتصف
نوفمبر ما وضع السعوديه في موقف حرج مش
السعوديه بس كل دول الخليج لكن السعوديه
تحديدا
ليه السعوديه تريد التهدئه مع الحوثيين
وحتى الان التزمت الحياد واكتفت رسميا
بمطالبه كل الاطراف بضبط النفس يعني طالبه
الامريكان وبريطانيا بضبط النفس وطالبت
الحوثيين بضبط النفس لكن قد يصعب على
السعوديه ان طل امد الصراع ان تظل على
الحياد مثلا قد يستهدف الحوثيون بضرباته
البحرين او مقر الاسطول الخامس الامريكي
اللي بتستي فه البحرين استقرار البحرين
امر مهم
للسعوديه تداعيات اشتباك الامريكان
والحوثيين الذين قد يستهدفون القوات
والمصالح الامريكيه في دول الخليج الاخرى
قد يجبر السعوديه ودول الخليج على على
التخلي عن حيادهم والتدخل مرغمين
صعب على السعوديه ان تقف على الحياد من
تحالف يسعى لضرب جماعه بتهدد امنها حتى
حين لا تستهدفها ازاي ما هو صواريخ الحوثي
اللي كانت بتضرب اسرائيل او بتستهدف
اسرائيل كانت احيانا بتمر عبر الاجواء
السعوديه ما يضطر الدفاعات الجويه
السعوديه للتعامل معها وبدئه اذا انضمت
السعوديه لهذا التحالف المعادي للحوثيين
فان هذا الانضمام يعني يعني نسف كل
مفاوضات السلام مع الحوثي والعوده للمربع
رقم
واحد اثنين حتى لو تمكنت السعوديه من
الوقوف على الحياد فان هذا لا يكفي للحفاظ
على سلامها الهش مع
الحوثيين يعني مثلا واشنطن قررت اعاده منذ
ايام اعاده الحوثيين لقوائم المنظمات
الارهابيه عقابا لهم على هجماتهم على
اسرائيل والملاحه الدوليه هذا من شانه ان
يعقد مفاوضات السلام مع الحوثيين لان احد
اهم شروط الحوثيين لتحقيق هذا السلام
والحصول
على رواتب لموظفيها الرواتب دي هتاتي منين
من عوائد البترول
والثروات المختلفه اللي بتسيطر عليها
الحكومه الشرعيه المقيمه في الرياض او من
السعوديه نفسها في شكل مساعدات يعني لا
تستطيع البنوك السعوديه عمل ذلك في حال
فرد عق عقوبات على الحوثيين لانه البنوك
في حال وجود عقوبات ده بيشل من حركتها
والا تتعرض العقوب البنوك السعوديه
للعقوبات
الامريكيه حتى لو تجاوزوا هذه العقبه
هيبقى قدامنا الاحتمال الثالث ان الاوضاع
في اليمن نفسها تسوء ليه تسوء ما هو من
المتوقع ان تتجنب
السفن الان كل الموانئ اليمنيه خصوصا م
الحديده وهو الميناء الرئيسي تحت سيطره
الحوثيين او تفرض اسعار اعلى بكثير
جدا علشان تعكس يعني ارتفاع المخاطر عليها
ان اقتربت من ميناء
الحديده تجنب السفن او العدد القليل منها
اللي هيخطب ويروح مناء الحديده ويرفع
تكاليفه هذا يعني ارتفاع كل يعني السلع
الاساسيه الذاهبه الى اليمن اللي بيست
بيستورد معظم احتياجاته من الخارج وخصوصا
الطعام الاكثر من ذلك او الاسوا من ذلك ان
المجلس الانتقالي الجنوبي الساع للانفصال
وتاسيس دوله في جنوب
اليمن ربما يسعى لاستغلال الموقف ليقدم
نفسه على انه شريك فعال للغرب وقادر على
المساعده في تامين مديق باب المندب
وبالتالي يدخل في ا اشتباك كاتن او يشتبك
مجددا مع الحوثيين هذا من شانه ان يشعل
الحرب مجددا في هذا البلد المنقسم على
نفسه واذا حدث ذلك من الصعب ان تناى دول
الجوار بنفسها عن الصراع الدائر في اليمن
ولابد ان تكون في معسكر واضح ولن يكون هذا
المعسكر الواضح على الارجح هو معسكر
الحوثيين السبب الرابع لموقف الدول
العربيه باستثناء البحرين اللي جعلها تنى
بنفسها عن الهجمات الامريكيه على الحوثيين
رغم الضرر الواقع عليهم من الموقف الحوثي
هو ادراكهم لعدم جدوى هذه الضربات
الامريكيه
البريطانيه التاريخ ال القريب جدا بيؤكد
لنا انه السعوديه وهي دوله قويه عسكريا
والامارات وهي دوله قويه عسكريا
تحالف مع عدد اخر من دول المنطقه ودعمتهم
دول كبرى على ارسيه امريكا
وبريطانيا وشنوا هجوما على الحوثي منذ
2015 وحتى يعني
ا نهايه
2021 لكنهم فشلوا تماما في هزيمه الحوثي
تماما الحوثي اثبت انه اقوى بكثير مما كان
يعتقد خصومه في
2015 وهذا ياخذنا الى مصادر قوه الحوث
العسكريه ودي قصه طويله لكن لكن في تقديري
انه في عناصر كده مصادر قوه الحوثي ست او
سبع عناصر اساسيه السبب الاولاني انه
جماعه الحوثي وكل من ينضم اليهم يعني من
حلفاء داخل اليمن اكتسبوا مهارات عسكريه
لا يستهان بها واتقن ادوات الحروب غير
التقليديه خلال سنوات الحرب الطويله مع
التحالف الذي قادته السعوديه وقبل هذا
الحرب حروبهم اللي سبقت ذلك ضد علي عبد
الله صالح او يعني ضد السعوديين انفسهم
فيما
سبق اثنين انه هم طبعا بيستفيدوا بشكل جيد
من الجغرافيا الصعبه لليمن وبيستخدموا
كحصن طبيعيه ثلاثه الحوثيون وحلفائهم
ليسوا حساسين للخسائر البشريه في صفوفهم
او في البنيه التحتيه يعني قارن كده مثلا
بين الخوف الاسرائيلي او الخوف الامريكي
من تعرض قواتهم لخسائر والاثر المحدود جدا
لهذه الخسائر على صناع القرار في الحوثيين
او جماعه
طالبان قارن مثلا بين الاثر العنيف لتعرض
دوله مثل الامارات لهجمات صاروخيه وبين
اثر تعرض صنعاء او المدن اليمنيه الاخرى
لنفس الضربات لماذا قصه طويله تتضافر فيها
الاسباب الدينيه مفهوم الشهاده وبصراحه
الفقر برض الامارات مثلا لديها بنيه تحتيه
متطوره تخشى عليها في اليمن لا توجد بنيه
تحتيه تذكر هي افقر دوله في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وفقا لتقديرات البنك الدولي
وبالتالي مما يخافون اربعه الحوثي
والجماعات المماثله ليست مهتمه لاسباب
كثيره بتاثير العقوبات على اقتصادها هي
تاقلمت على العزل عن العالم ليس مهما ان
تجمد اموالها ليس لها اموال اصلا في
الخارج ليس مهما
مثلا ان تح تهددها بحجب تكنولوجيات متطوره
عنها هذا لا
يعنيها خامسا تمكن الحوثي من امتلاك
ترسانه فعاله من السلاح حصل على بعضها من
الجيش اليمني الذي انضمت وحدات منه للحوثي
بدايه من
2015 واشترى اسلحه من خصومه داخل اليمن
كانوا قد حصلوا عليها من التحالف الذي
قادته السعوديه بالاضافه الى تطوير اسلحه
بخبرات محليه وبخبرات ايرانيه في دراسه
اعدها معهد امريكان انتربرايز نشرت في
الامريكي يعني نشرت في 14 مارس 2022 وهي
موجوده اظن على حوالي 80 صفحه دراسه جيده
سوف اضع لكم رابتها بتشير الى القدرات
العسكريه المتطوره للحوثي ولكن دي قصه
يطول شرحها لكن بتقول هم عندهم صواريخ
كروس وصواريخ بالستيه بعضها قادر ان يضرب
اهدافا على مسافه ا حوالي 1000 كيلو عندهم
اكثر من 1000 كيلو عندهم قوارب انتحاريه
لضرب السفن في
السواحل في السواحل اليمنيه عندهم طبعا
طائرات بدون طيار وهذه الطائرات قادره على
ان تضرب اهدافا على مسافه 1500 ك مترا هذه
القدرات مكنت الحوثيين من ضرب السعوديه
على سبيل المثال اثناء حربها مع الحوثيين
ب 430 صاروخ بالستي
و881 طائره مسيره من مارس
2015 وحتى ديسمبر
سادسا سادسا من مصادر قوه الحوثي انه
الجميع بيخى من مواجهه الحوثي تحسبا
للتكلفه العاليه جدا التي سوف يتحملها اي
تحالف يسعى لمواجهه
الحوثيين
لانه مواجهه الحوثي مثلا بتتطلب عمليه
عسكريه طويله قد تستمر لشهور بتكلفه
هائله التكلفه الهائله ديت هي محصله جمع
تكلفه العمليه العسكريه زائد تعطل التجاره
الدوليه في ثاني اهم شريان مائي في العالم
للتوضيح الحوثي مثلا يستطيع ان يهاجم
سفينه بدرون تكلفته حوالي 1000 دولار
التصدي ليه يتطلب اطلاق واحد على الاقل
تكلفته مليون دولار 1000 دولار مليون
دولار اللي هو 1000
ال000 لكن هذه حزبه ساذجه لو اقتصرنا على
كده بس الدرون اليمني موجود في ايدي
المقاتلين الحوثيين لكن الصاروخ يتطلب سفن
ومدمرات
حربيه تاتي من بلدانها بكل ما يتطلب ذلك
من تكلفه عاليه ثمن الصاروخ واحد منها
والتكلفه كلها على بعضها اللي هي تكلفه
التصدي للدرون الرخيص بصاروخ او اكثر ده
هو السيناريو الجيد في السيناريو السيء
السيناريو السيء ان هذا ان الصاروخ لا
يتمكن من اسقاط
الدرون الحوثي وبالتالي يصيب السفينه
الماره من السواحل اليمنيه ثمن السفينه في
المتوسط لا يقل عن 50 مليون دولار وبتحمل
ايضا في المتوسط بضائع لا تقل عن 500
مليون
دولار كل دي التكلفه المباشره اما التكلفه
غير مباشره فهي اكثر ما يقلق اي طرف يسعى
للصدام مع الحوثي وهو شل الملاحه في مديق
باب المندب وقناه السويس وخليج عدن لشهور
طويله ما يعني بالضروره ازمه اقتصاديه
كبرى طبعا كل ده انا ماتكلمتش على احتمال
ان تقوم الحوثي وهو الاحتمال المرجح
بمهاجمه المصالح والقواعد امريكيه في
المنطقه وسوف تجد الولايات المتحده نفسها
عرضه لهجمات الحوثي وحلفائه في العراق
وسوريا ولبنان وقطعا مهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات وغيرهما اذا تدخلت هذه
الدول في الحرب الدائره بين الحوثي
والامريكان طبعا كلنا نتذكر ما حدث مثلا
في عام
2019 لما الحوثيين هاجموا بطائرات مسيره
وصواريخ منشات نفطيه في شرق المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ادى الى توقف نصف انتاج
المملكه من النفط مؤقتا هذه الاسباب التي
تمنع الدول العربيه وغير العربيه من
المشاركه في ضرب الحوثي البحرين طبعا
الدوله العربيه والاسلاميه الوحيده التي
انضمت للامريكان لها حسابات مختلفه ودي
قصه يطول شرحها لكن باختصار البحرين دوله
صغيره مهدده ربما اكثر من غيرها من جانب
ايران على الاقل وفقا لتصورات ساستها وهي
تواجه هذا الخطر بعده وسائل اهمها التحالف
مع الولايات المتحده التي منحتها وضعا
مميزا من خلال معاده وقعتها مع وقعها
البلدين يعني في 2002 في 2002 تجعل من
البحرين حليفا رئيسيا للولايات المتحده من
خارج النيتو يعني تحظى بضمانات اعضاء حلف
النيتو لكنها ليست جزءا من حلف النيتو ثم
عززت امريكا هذا التحالف بتوقيع اتفاقيه
امنيه واقتصاديه استراتيجيه شامله في
سبتمبر
2023 هذه الاتفاقات بتمن ح البحرين مظله
دفاع امريكيه ضد اي عدوان محتمل عليها
لازم يكون المقابل ان تثبت البحرين
للولايات المتحده اهميتها لها كيف يمكن ان
تثبت ذلك بان هي تساعدها في تحقيق اهدافها
في المنطقه في كل الاحوال البحرين وهو
الاهم لا تستطيع ان تناى بنفسها عن هذه
العمليه باعتبار البحرين هي المقر الرئيسي
للاسطول الخامس للبحريه الامريكيه اللي هو
هيكون ضالع في الهجوم على الحوثيين وفي
الغالب سوف تكون هي مقر القوات البحريه
المشتركه التي تنسق عمليات التحالف حارس
الازدهار او غيره ا اللي
بتنسق يعني العمليه العسكريه البحريه في
المنطقه والهجمات على الحوثي كل ما قلته
لا يعني ان الحوثيين قوه لا تقهر ويجب على
الجميع ان يستسلم لها وينصاع الى اوامرها
يمكن هزيمه الحوثي ولكن بتكلفه وثمن باهظ
جدا كما اثبتت السنوات الطويله من
المواجهه بين الحوثيين والتحالف الذي
قادته المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي حقيقه
الامر على العالم ان
يتصالح ويقبل بوجود قوه كبيره الان وفعاله
في شمال اليمن هم الحوثيين سواء احببنا
ذلك ام كرهناه ولكن هذه قصه اخرى يطول
شرحها الامر الثاني والاهم ان محاوله ضرب
الحوثيين عقابا لهم على تضامنهم مع
الفلسطينيين ودعمهم لقضيه عادله هو خطا
كبير يضاف الى سلسله اخطاء الرئيس بايدن
في السياسه الخارجيه سلسله كبيره من
الاخطاء كتيره بس ده مش موضوعنا لكن كلنا
نتذكر باختصار الاصرار على استمرار الحرب
في اوكرانيا حتى بعد ان ثبت عدم جدواها
ارتكب خطا فادحا بالدعم المطلق لنتنياهو
وحكومته المتطرفه التي يتهمها اسرائيليون
بانها تسعى لاطاله امد الحرب بما يتعارض
مع مصالح الاسرائيليين انفسهم فضلا عن
مصالح امريكا
نفسها وترتب على هذا الخطا الثاني اندلاع
هجمات الحوثيين
ويضاعف اداره بايدن خطاها قررت علاج
هجمات الحوثيين باسوا حل ممكن وهو
الاستمرار في دعم اسرائيل وضرب الحوثيين
الامر الذي يعني بالضروره توسيع نطاق
الحرب في المنطقه والتي اعلنت امريكا كما
قلت لكم انها لا لا تسعى ابدا
لتوسيعها الدعم المطلق لاسرائيل ليس هو
السبب الوحيد هناك سوء التقدير والاعتماد
المفرط للاداره الامريكيه او للامريكان
على القوه امريكا لم تعد تملك غير القوه
لفرض ارادتها على الجميع والمثل الامريكي
بيقول اذا كانت الاداه الوحيده التي
تملكها هي الشاكوش فسوف ترى كل المشاكل
مصامير السيد بايدن سئل هل هجماتك على
الحوثي سوف توقف هجماتهم على البلاح
البحريه قال لا ولكنني سوف اواصل الهجوم
عليهم اشكركم والى اللقاء